so literally in the last few moments
we've had an update from
the palace in which they have said that
the duke of edinburgh was today
transferred from the king edward vii
hospital to some bartholomew's hospital
where doctors will continue to treat him
for an infection
as well as undertake testing and
observation for a pre-existing
heart condition so this has just come
through from the palace now
they also say that the duke remains
comfortable and is responding to
treatment but
is expected to remain in hospital until
at least
the end of the week so just to confirm
the details that we've had
prince philip has now left the king
edward the seventh hospital
he has instead been transferred to some
bartholomew's hospital
and the doctors there are continuing to
treat him for an infection which it was
confirmed by the palace he was being
treated for
here they confirmed that last week they
also say that doctors are now
undertaking testing and observation for
a pre-existing heart condition
i think also some reassurance from the
palace here in which they say that the
duke remains comfortable
and is responding to treatment but they
go on to say that he is
expected to remain in hospital until at
least the end
of the week now this confirmation from
the palace
comes after we saw much more activity
around the hospital
first thing this morning at around eight
o'clock police started putting out more
barriers
around one of the entrances and exits to
the hospital we also saw more police
arrive at the time as well to try and
potentially
obscure the exit from view from the
banks of cameras
and photographers who've been here right
throughout the last
couple of weeks since the duke was
admitted to hospital
the pictures that i think we can show
you now will show
that it was quite difficult for the
cameras to see
but shot through a police van window you
could see that two umbrellas
had been put in place to try and obscure
the view for photographers
and cameras as it appears the duke of
edinburgh was being taken
out of the hospital and then put into an
ambulance the ambulance then drove away
and around 10 minutes after that a range
rover then followed the ambulance we
didn't know exactly
where that ambulance was going we
suspected that the duke may well have
been being taken back to windsor castle
where of course he's been spending time
right throughout the pandemic alongside
her majesty the queen
but just confirm in the last five
minutes or so it has been confirmed by
the hospital that he has in fact been
taken to
saint bartholomew's hospital they're
continuing to treat him
for an infection but also they
are undertaking testing and observation
for a pre-existing
um heart condition and symptomates just
to give you a bit more detail is a
internationally renowned hospital in the
city of london it's quite close to saint
paul's cathedral so it wouldn't have
taken them that long for him to get
there
uh it's also a center of excellence for
both cardiac
and cancer care so that is now where
prince philip
is undergoing more treatment we know
that he was admitted here to the king
edward the seventh hospital
almost two weeks ago the palace at the
time said that he was able to walk into
the hospital unaided he wasn't brought
here
under any sense of emergency they said
that doctors at the time were acting
with
an abundance of caution as you would
anticipate they would
he is after all 99 years old due to turn
100
in june so yeah the latest update from
the palace he has left the king edward
the seventh hospital but is now being
treated
at some bartholomew's hospital which is
close to paul's cathedral